what we're now going to think about is
finding the differences between sets and
the first way that we will denote this
is we'll start with set a I've already
defined set a let me do it in that same
shade of green I've already defined set
a here and in both cases I've defined
these sets with numbers I could have had
the instead of having numbers as being
the objects in the set I could have had
farm animals there are famous presidents
but numbers hopefully keep things fairly
simple so I'm going to start with set
set a and from set a I'm going to
subtract I am going to subtract set B so
this is one way of thinking about the
difference between set a and set B and
when I've written it this way this is
essentially says give me the set of all
of the objects that are in a with the
things that are in B taken out of that
set so let's think about what that means
so what's in set a what the things that
are in B taken out well that means let's
take set a and take out a 17 a 19 or
take out the 17 the 19th and the 6is so
we're going to be left with we're going
to have the 5 we're going to have the 3
we're not going to have the 17 because
we subtracted out set B 17 is in set B
so take out anything that is in set B so
you get the 5 the 3 C the 12 is not in
set B so we can keep that in there and
then the 19 is in set B so we're going
to take out the 19 as well and so that
is this right over here is you could
view it as set B subtracted from set a
so one way of thinking about it like we
just said this is these are all of the
elements that are in set a that are not
in set B another way you could think
about it is these are all of the
elements that are not in set B but also
in set a so let me make it clear this
you could view this as as be subtracted
subtracted from from a or you could view
this as the relative complement relative
r-la I always have trouble spelling
things relative relative complement
complement of set B
in a and we're going to talk a lot more
about compliments in the future but the
compliment is the things that are not in
B and so this is saying look what are
all of the things that are not in B so
you could say what are all of the things
not in B not in B but are in a so once
again if you said all the things that
aren't in B then you're thinking about
all of the numbers in the whole universe
that aren't 1719 or 6 and actually you
could even think broader not even just
thinking about numbers it could even be
the color orange is not in set B so that
would be in the absolute complement of B
you have I don't see a zebra here in set
B so that would be its complement but
we're saying what are the things that
are not in B but are in a and that would
be the numbers 5 3 and 12 now when we
when we visualized this as B subtracted
from a you might be saying hey wait look
look okay I could imagine you took the
17 out you took the 19 out but what
about taking the 6 out shouldn't have
you taken a 6 outer you know and
traditional subtraction maybe we would
end up with a negative number or
something and when you subtract a set if
this is set you're subtracting from does
not have that element then taking that
element out of it doesn't change it if I
start with set a and take a 6 if I take
all the sixes out of set a doesn't
change it there was no 6 to begin with I
could take all the zebras out of set a
it will not change it now another way to
denote this the relative complement of
set B in a or b subtracted from a is the
notation that I'm about to write you we
could have written it this way a and
then we would have had this little
figure like this that looks eerily like
a division sign II really like a
division sign but this also means the
difference between set a and B where
we're talking about when we write it
this way we're talking about all of the
things in set a that are not in set B or
the things in set be taken out of set a
or the relative complement of B in a now
with that out of the way let's think
about things the other way around what
would what would be what would be slash
I'll just call it a slash right over
here what would be B or it what would be
B - a
be so what would be B minus a which we
could also write it as which we could
also write as B B minus a what would
this be equal to well just going back to
this we could view this as all the
things in B with all of the things in a
taken out of it or all of the things the
complement of a that happens to be in B
so let's think of it as the set B with
all the things in a taken out of it so
if we start with set B okay we have a 17
but a 17 is in set a so we have to take
the 17 out then we have a 19 oh but
there's a 19 in set a so we have to take
the 19 out then we have a 6 oh well we
don't have to take a 6 out of B because
the 6 is not in set a so we're left with
just the 6 so this would be just the
single the the set with a single element
in it set 6 now let me ask another
question what would what would the
relative complement of a in a be well
this is the same thing as a minus a and
this is literally saying let's take set
a and then take all the things that are
in set a out of it well I start with a 5
oh but there's already 5 there's a 5 in
set a so if I take a 5 out well there's
a 3 but there's a 3 in set a so I have
to take a 3 out so I'm going to take all
of these things out and so I'm just
going to be left with I'm just going to
be left with the empty set the empty set
often called the null set and sometimes
the notation for that will look like
this the null set the empty set there's
a set that has absolutely no objects in
it